[Aplausos]
[Música]
ucrania es algo así como el julen
lopetegui de los países últimamente solo
da malas noticias en las últimas décadas
ucrania ha sido el escenario del peor
accidente nuclear de la historia un
conflicto armado y todos los escándalos
de corrupción que os podáis imaginar
[Música]
es más los políticos ucranianos tienen
otra cosa en común con lopetegui también
tienen los bolsillos llenos de dinero
tras la caída de la unión soviética la
economía pasó de estar en manos del
estado a estar en manos de los amigos
del estado ahí tenemos a sergey tigipko
por ejemplo ex vicepresidente y banquero
o a yulia timoshenko la ex presidenta
conocida como la princesa del gas eso
por no hablar del actual presidente
petro poroshenko dueño de la principal
empresa de chocolate del país
[Música]
en otras palabras que todo cambio para
que no cambiará nada es más es ahora
cuando empezamos a ver cambios en
ucrania pero no son cambios a mejor más
bien todo lo contrario veréis en el
anterior vídeo de esta serie os
contábamos cómo rusia es el principal
proveedor de gas de europa por ejemplo
alemania compra el 60 por ciento de su
gas natural a empresas rusas como
gazprom rosneft y de dónde viene todo
ese gas pues casi todo viene por los
gasoductos que cruzan ucrania y todo
esto que significa pues que aunque
ucrania apenas tenga recursos de gas es
un país clave en este negocio y si aquí
es cuando entra en escena nuestro
querido amigo el único el inigualable
vladimir putin
a día de hoy putin necesita ucrania para
poder suministrar de gas a europa y como
ya sabéis las relaciones entre moscú y
kiev están ahora mismo en es complicado
como dirían les luthiers el amor eterno
dura aproximadamente 10 años así que
después de décadas de amor y fraternidad
eslava el gobierno de polos en que
quiere alejarse todo lo que puede del
kremlin y como os podéis imaginar este
divorcio político no le hace la más
mínima gracia a rusia cada vez que su
gas cruza el territorio ucraniano tiene
que pagar un peaje millonario a su
exmujer
pero no sólo eso veréis mientras ucrania
esté en el centro de la ruta del gas el
gobierno de kier tiene una paja para
poder negociar con rusia o con la unión
europea dicho de otra forma a día de hoy
la importancia de ucrania a nivel
internacional reside en que les
necesitamos para poder tener gas así que
cuál es la estrategia de putin pues
exactamente está
[Música]
los rusos insisten en un nuevo gasoducto
para sortear ucrania y en los europeos
les parece bien si amigos de visual
política la estrategia de rusia consiste
en aislar a ucrania en las rutas del gas
de este modo ucrania perdería todo su
interés estratégico y eso significa que
ni la unión europea ni eeuu movería en
un dedo para defenderlos ante una nueva
y posible invasión rusa así que la
pregunta es realmente puede funcionar
esta estrategia para aislar a ucrania de
verdad europa va a permitir que ucrania
se quede a la intemperie hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
no eres mía no serás de nadie en el año
2000 el 70 por ciento del gas que
llegaba a europa venía a través de
ucrania más concretamente por el llamado
gasoducto brotherhood esta tubería se
construyó en tiempos de la unión
soviética y su importancia que decía a
medida que crecía a la demanda de gas el
otro 30% viene por el gasoducto yamal
que está en bielorrusia pero eso es otra
historia en el momento en el que se
desintegra la unión soviética ucrania se
convierte en un país independiente y es
en ese momento cuando él quiere empiezan
a ver el business
si rusia tiene las reservas de gas en
siberia y está usando mi territorio para
llegar con su tubería baviera ya estoy
tardando en exigirles un peaje veréis
ahora mismo ese peaje son más de dos mil
millones de dólares anuales pero ha
llegado a ser mucho más en el pasado
gracias a los llamados derechos de
tránsito la compañía estatal de gas
ucraniano naftogaz se convirtió en una
de las más grandes del país y todo esto
pese a que en ucrania casi no hay
yacimientos pero como os podéis imaginar
esto es mucho más que economía tanto en
rusia como en ucrania todo es
susceptible de ser convertido en un arma
política
así que cuando quiere tenía un gobierno
pro ruso gazprom dejaba el gas a precio
de amigo pero en el momento en el que
quiere dejó de tener un gobierno
prorruso los precios se dispararon ya os
lo contamos en el primer vídeo de esta
serie las negociaciones a cara de perro
entre rusia y ucrania llevaron a los
ucranianos a quedarse sin gas en el año
2006 y 2009 y en este último corte el de
2009 también se quedó sin gas casi toda
europa y ahí es cuando rusia aprovechó
la coyuntura útil llamó por teléfono al
ex canciller alemán y actual presidente
de rosneft gerhard schroeder y gerhard
schroeder llamó a la actual canciller
alemana angela merkel así es como se
vendió el primer proyecto para evitar a
ucrania en los envíos de gas el llamado
gasoducto nord stream 1 que pasa por
debajo del mar báltico poco después en
el año 2010
yanukóvich ganó la presidencia de
ucrania yanukóvich era un presidente
prorruso así que la calma y los precios
bajos volvieron al país
[Música]
pero de nuevo en el año 2014 tuvimos el
euro maidán meses de protestas que se
llevaron por delante a yanukóvich y que
trajeron a un gobierno totalmente anti
ruso y en ese momento es cuando putin
dijo eso de si no eres mía no serás de
nadie desde 2015 gazprom que es la
principal gasística rusa comienza el
plan definitivo para sortear a ucrania
de una vez por todas por un lado
comienza la construcción del nord string
2 por el báltico por el otro lado en el
sur
gazprom ya está trabajando en el tarc
stream que va por el mar negro
[Música]
según el presidente de gazprom en el año
2020 ese gasoducto brote del que
hablábamos antes transportar a sólo un
10 por ciento del gas que bombea ahora
pero esperad un momento porque he dicho
así parece que los rusos son muy malos y
los ucranianos son unos pobres
desamparados pues para nada ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
[Música]
el gigante ucraniano naftogas es mucho
más que una compañía de gas es toda una
oficina de empleo tiene nada menos que
175 mil empleados para que os hagáis una
idea su homóloga en polonia peguen y que
también es estatal sólo tiene 25 mil
trabajadores en otras palabras que en
ucrania te miran mal si no tienes a un
cuñado trabajando en auto gas creo que
hasta lopetegui les ha enviado un
currículum a ver si cuela
[Música]
[Aplausos]
como os podéis imaginar naftogas es un
auténtico agujero negro en las finanzas
de ucrania pero no sólo eso su mayor
problema es que cuando los contratos van
pasando por tantas manos en una empresa
estatal se van cómo decirlo cayendo los
millones según un think-tank de kiev que
se llama el institute for economic
research and policy consulting la
corrupción en apto gas supone más de
tres mil millones de dólares al año
hablamos de una empresa que
sistemáticamente da pérdidas
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea las pérdidas
de 2014 llegaban a ser un 6% de todo el
pib de ucrania pero justo en ese año en
2014 surgió el euro maidana y en ucrania
se sucedieron cambios muy rápidos
cambios como éste
la policía ucraniana detiene a heaven
bakulin consejero delegado de naftogaz
el nuevo ceo de la empresa es este señor
que veis aquí andrid cobol y es un
consultor que por aquel entonces no
tenía ni 40 años el trabajo de cobo liev
se podría resumir en dos objetivos uno
acabar con la corrupción 2 a acabar con
la dependencia de rusia y no creáis que
hablamos de palabras vacías tanto la
unión europea como el fmi han presionado
a ucrania para que haga sus deberes y
eso explica cosas como esta ya storage
europa anuncia nuevas mejoras de la
iniciativa de transparencia del
almacenamiento con la unión de naftogaz
de ucrania al inventario de
almacenamiento de gas desde entonces
naftogas ha empezado a dar beneficios
por primera vez en décadas de hecho ha
dejado de ser un agujero en el
presupuesto para empezar a aportar el
estado el 13 por ciento de los ingresos
y os preguntaréis como lo ha hecho como
líder pues como suele pasar con los
monopolios estatales el gas era tan
barato
que los ucranianos tenían puesta la
calefacción hasta en agosto naftogas ha
subido el precio que pagaban los
consumidores poniéndolo a un nivel
parecido al del resto de europa
[Música]
fueron otro lado cobol ya le ha plantado
cara a putin con una cosa que podríamos
llamar pensamiento lateral veréis
gazprom quería subir el precio del gas a
ucrania pero no al resto de países
europeos así que que ha hecho un acto
gas pues muy sencillo recomprar el gas
ruso a otros países como eslovaquia
los contratos con gazprom establecen que
cuando el gas era un país de la unión
europea-rusia pierde el control sobre el
gas y el país en cuestión puede hacer lo
que quiera con él por ejemplo el gas
llega eslovaquia a través del gasoducto
brotherhood y después vuelve por el
mismo camino hasta ucrania
de esta forma naftogas ha reducido el
coste de importar gas a una cuarta parte
pero esto es sólo el principio
-comunidad sigue buscando alternativas
por ejemplo a azerbaiyán como ya hemos
explicado en otros vídeos azerbaiyán
está construyendo el gasoducto transan a
tool jan que llega hasta italia
pues bien quien quiere poder se
enchufará esta tubería a través de
bulgaria y si ya sé lo que estáis
pensando en toda esta historia del gas
ruso el más claro ganador es a
azerbaiyán pero de eso vamos a hablar en
el siguiente vídeo por cierto que si más
lo queréis perder y ya sabéis
suscribiros a visual político y darle a
la campanita pero volvamos a ucrania
porque parece que este país está
limpiando la corrupción verdad puedes
esperar un momento porque como siempre
decimos en visual político no todo es
tan bonito
[Música]
para que ucrania se pueda adaptar del
todo a europa tendría que liberalizar su
mercado del gas es decir que naftogaz
perdería su condición de monopolio y se
tendría que dividir en varias empresas
al menos una dedicada a la producción de
gas otra dedicada al suministro en fin
una empresa independiente para cada
actividad y aquí es donde llegan los
problemas
[Música]
la unión europea y ucrania en un tira y
afloja sobre la división de naftogaz
como os podéis imaginar por mucho que
como les quiera limpiar la empresa hay
demasiados oligarcas que llevan décadas
viviendo muy bien si la empresa puede
ser todo lo estatal que queráis pero eso
no quita que no haya mucha gente
cobrando sueldos millonarios y
llevándose mordidas muy pero que muy
jugosas y eso es casi imposible de
erradicar de un día para otro pero esto
no es lo peor
veréis en marzo de 2019 ucrania volverá
a tener elecciones y el resultado va a
ser decisivo para el futuro de naftogas
y mis queridos amigos de visual política
rusia ya tiene una hoja de ruta bien
marcada ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
competitividad versus geopolítica
alemania ya lo ha dejado claro van a
construir el gasoducto nord stream 2
tanto bruselas como washington están en
contra de este proyecto
de hecho las críticas más duras son las
de donald trump que ya ha dicho que
hasta el beti podría diseñar mejor la
estrategia energética de alemania
[Música]
y os preguntaréis cómo es posible que
angela merkel se haya dejado seducir por
vladimir putin si vale el otro día os
decíamos que el ex canciller alemán
gerhard schroeder es el hombre de putin
en europa pero hay mucho más que todo
eso básicamente alemania tiene un dilema
de los gordos por un lado su industria
necesita gas mucho gas y cuanto más
barato y seguro mejor así que si
dejáramos la geopolítica a un lado y nos
centraremos en la economía el nord
stream 2 es sin lugar a dudas la mejor
opción primero porque es barato y
segundo porque evita todos los problemas
que conlleva el tránsito por ucrania
cuál es el problema pues que ese
gasoducto va a hacer que alemania
dependa aún más de rusia no sólo eso
también dejaría a la intemperie a uno de
los aliados de la unión europea que es
ucrania
mientras tanto putin está encantado de
la vida no sólo puede aislar a ucrania
del tránsito de gas sino que también
puede ahogar la económicamente en este
sentido la siente
del kremlin son más obvias que cuando tu
ex novia te llama para tomar un café y
no sólo hablamos del gas por ejemplo
mira de este mapa
[Música]
y esto de aquí es el mar negro ucrania
tiene dos puertos importantes aquí y
aquí pues bien rusia ha construido un
puente justo aquí en crimea que
consiguen con este puente pues
básicamente que muchos barcos no puedan
cruzar el estrecho y os preguntaréis
pero porque rusia quiere arruinar a
ucrania pues muy sencillo cuanto peor le
vaya al gobierno anti ruso de kiev más
facilidades tendrán los candidatos pro
rusos y diréis pero hay algún candidato
prorruso con posibilidad real de ganar
las elecciones de 2019 y la respuesta es
que todo es posible en ucrania para que
os hagáis una idea en este país tienen
una serie de televisión muy conocida se
llama el servidor público
el protagonista es un profesor que lucha
contra la corrupción pues bien ya se ha
registrado un partido político con el
nombre de la serie y donde el candidato
es el actor protagonista que se llama
por cierto vladimir selenski tiene
posibilidades de ganar pues
no os lo voy a contar miradlo a vosotros
mismos
[Música]
timoshenko líder en las encuestas de
candidatos presidenciales seguida por
poroshenko del ine ski y here isenco
habéis oído bien está en el tercer
puesto detrás de la princesa del gas y
el rey del chocolate vamos que es casi
imposible predecir lo que va a pasar
[Música]
hay una cosa clara en esta historia un
actor que a todas luces sale ganando de
todo esto y ese es a azerbaiyán pero de
eso vamos a hablar en el siguiente vídeo
mientras tanto la pregunta es para
vosotros qué haríais si fuerais a
alemania- aceptaríais el gas barato de
rusia a cambio de dejar a ucrania sola o
sacrificar y aix la competitividad por
los intereses políticos podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
mientras tanto si os ha gustado este
vídeo suscribiros a visual pólit y dadle
a light y nos vemos en el próximo un
abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]